yeah so this is a bit of a blast from
the past so some time ago one of my
colleagues made a comment about zinc
being boring and I thought we'd take
that comment and examine it in a little
bit more detail and what I could show
that was actually zinc is quite exciting
because you can use it as a basis for
what is basically a pocket flamethrower
wolf now when we did this experiment
there was a beautiful yellow flame came
out of this but I'm told and I'd know
from reading around that actually this
flame should be blue and we think that
it's yellow because I did it with this
syringe here which has we think sodium
contaminants that get into the flame and
hence make it yellow and we'd really
like to see this blue color because this
was the description of it the very first
time this compound was made over 100
years ago and so today we're going to
try this with this syringe now this
syringe is made out of plastic and the
idea is that there shouldn't be any
contamination from this in the flame and
together with some of the new very
high-speed cameras that we've got access
to we're hoping we can get a glimpse of
this blue flash in the flame
this is diethyl zinc in this syringe and
as you can see it looks harmless
yeah it looks to be water for anyone
would know okay here we go
I'd say we got some blue
so up to about 900 oh here we go
awesome yeah yeah that's a blue well we
could see blue so that's the most
important thing what are you doing now
I'm going to do it again
my passion for die files ink comes from
the phrase we uses pyrophoric pyrophoric
means it's spontaneously catches fire in
air
there we go look asthma's a few drops
yet you see when the oxygen exposure to
the droplets is maximized the blue
colors maximized yeah
my guess is as we see more and more
material it look whiter and brighter yes
which it does and you cause you see blue
right on the edges this compound was
first discovered by Franklin it
describes in his original notes how he
had a glass vial full of this compound
and he cut the top off and put a few
drops of water in and he says at that
point I observed a spontaneous blue
flame about a yard long in fact actually
that's not true because I've rerun
Franklin's experiment and what happens
is that you generate a massive cloud of
steam so what I think happened is that
Franklin bottled it he put a couple of
drops in saw this huge quantity of white
steam vapor coming out and at that point
he just threw the flask away from him
and as you've seen it's that contact
with the air that generates the blue
frame so he suddenly got a massive
increase in surface area I think and
that's what led to the the beautiful
blue flame now I think it's time for the
control experiment where we go back to
the original glass syringe and see if
there's a genuine difference or not
while I never believed in that one as
well
I'm a little surprised by that and I'm
starting to wonder if the last time I
did it I simply squirted it out too
quickly because I think what we've
definitely seen today is the slower you
release this material out into the world
that the better the chance of seeing the
blue scientists in me thinks we need to
do some more experiments Brady come back
sink a disco or something like that
so you can see that again a discharge of
high potential discharge is going across
this tube that is basically your body
can't metabolize copper properly it's
actually an inherited disease